Hi, welcome back and thank you for your interest in learning more about world building for
virtual production.
In this lesson, we'll be quickly getting an overview of parent and instance materials.
So let's get right into it.
To display it, you can find a few steps you can follow for the development of a very basic
material setup.
But let's dive directly into the engine and review a parent material together with its
material instance.
All right, so we're in our original map.
But to keep things simple, I'm just gonna go under file and new level and create a very
basic level.
All right, down here, we're not gonna use the player start.
So I'm just gonna click on it and delete it.
And then I want to add from the quick add menu, a very simple cube.
So I'll navigate to shapes and cube.
All right, then I want to zero out the location down here in the details panel.
And I want to swap out this cube with a preview mesh, preview material zero one mesh, which
is typically used to preview materials.
All right, now we want to assign a different material to this preview mesh.
And I already have something in mind.
So I'm gonna make sure to have the highest folder in our project here key selected.
And then I'm gonna search for MI for material instance on the score floor.
Now a material instance is a child of a parent material that lets you change specific parameters
without creating an entirely new material.
And we'll open it up in just a second.
So you understand what I mean, using material instances saves performance because our engine
just needs to compile the parent materials shader once and all its instances can share
that compiled the shader code and just swap out the parameters values in real time.
So let's assign this specific material to our preview mesh by clicking it in the content
browser and then drag and dropping it on top of the preview mesh.
Now if we navigate again into a details panel down here into the element zero, you will
find the MI floor assigned.
So if we double click on the thumbnail, we'll be able to open this material instance up.
You can see that we have a few parameters here that we can play around with.
And if we click on them, it will be activated.
These parameters are values that we have consciously exposed in the parent material to have them
accessible in each instance of it.
So if we wanted to up here, we could for example, change the color.
And if I undo this material instance and then start changing the color right here, you can
see that these changes are happening in real time.
OK, now let's scroll a little bit down here and we can find the parent material connected
to this instance.
So if we double click again on this thumbnail, we will be able to open up the parent material.
So let's just talk both of them back into our workspace and navigate to M underscore
backing, which is the parent material.
OK, if we zoom into the material graph, you can see that we have the base color, the metallic
and the roughness exposed as parameters.
Let's try to add a texture to our preview mesh.
So if I right click in an empty area of the graph and then search for texture, you will
see up here already selected the texture sample.
So let's click on it to create a texture sample node.
And then we want to be able to expose it to our material instance.
So I'm just going to right click on it and then convert to parameter.
We can call this parameter main texture, and I'm going to connect the RGB to the base
color of our material.
Now, Unreal is going to complain because we haven't assigned any texture to our texture
sample. So if we select the node and then scroll down here, we can find a main texture
slot and I'm just going to add to it the icon green.
Now let's save these changes and apply.
Now if we go back to our material instance and then open up the global texture parameter
values, you will find our main texture parameter here exposed.
If we enable it, we will be able to change it on the fly.
So if we end up this window again, and we navigate to our level, you will be able to
find this main texture, apply to our preview mesh.
And if we change it to something else, like the analog hat, then it will change to this
bullseye directly.
So I know this little demo was short, but I hope it helped giving you an overall idea
of what materials are and how to use them.
Let's switch back to the slides and take a look at how we can best use the material instances
to our advantage in a project.
All right, so we mentioned already that material instances are really useful to save memory
overhead and performance.
But keep in mind that if all the texturing and shading of a whole environment were to
originate from one single master material, and then there were like 1000 material instances
assigned to each element of this environment, then your GPU performance will still be quite
impacted.
For this reason, it's a good practice to create different parent materials for different
kinds of surfaces like rocks, trees, water, and so on.
And then create instances of those different categories of surfaces directly.
This way, you'll still be using material instances in your project that will keep your VRAM in
place.
All right, that was it for this class.
I hope you had a good time.
Thank you to Sean Spitzer for the creation of this course.
You can find some additional documentation at this link if you're interested in further
expanding your knowledge in physically based materials or materials overall.
I'd also encourage you to take a look at our courses focused on materials on our platform,
because they will dive into this concept in better details.
Thank you for sticking around, and in the upcoming lesson, we will look into the foliage
tool.
I'll see you there.
Bye.